[Music]
foreign
dragons are no doubt the most famous and
fearsome of monsters so here in this
video we will showcase 9 upcoming
dragons from movies slated for this year
and next year with a couple that have
been recently released and others that
are in the making so let's get to it
number one temperature this first one
here in this list is from the new movies
called Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves he is a fat dragon and despite
not being the final enemy temperature is
a scary and funny Dragon that nearly
kills all the protagonists also known as
the wormsmith of grassland he is an
adult red dragon linked with drurgar of
the underdog who would practically
worship this creature the Adoration was
motivated by the creature's massive fire
breath which he used to Heat and Fuel
Dragon City forges as shown in the movie
he is portrayed as being exceedingly
overweight lethargic as well and unable
to fly because of his weight there are
also other dragons in the movie so go
check it out
number two Laden this one is seen in
Shazam Fury of the Gods he is a dragon
who protects the garden of the
Hesperides and was summoned to be the
daughters of atlas's principal enforcer
it grew to be faithful to Calypso one of
the three goddesses released to the
World by Shazam after breaking the staff
it was summoned becoming Calypso's Mount
and monster for a valid reason Leyden is
renowned as the world eater it was nasty
it was a chaotic enormous Beast as well
and was wooden in nature for some reason
it also had magical fire breath Laden is
protective of the golden apples but when
it becomes Calypso's enforcer it
subverts its characteristic and does all
in its power to help her conquer and
subdue humans in the earth in the end
though it would be killed but at what
cause
number three Bowser released this month
on the 5th of April Super Mario Bros is
as of now the highest grossing movie of
this year this animated flake features
the usual lot Mario Luigi Peach and
Bowser so for those who don't know who
Bowser is well Bowser is a large
powerful and anthropomorphic King of the
Koopas a tribe of turtle slash dragon
creatures that inhabit the Mushroom
Kingdom he is often depicted as having
an armored shell with spikes and a
variety of other special abilities such
as the ability to breathe Fireballs
throw Hammers and create shockwaves
Bowser's main goal is usually to kidnap
Princess Peach the rule of the Mushroom
Kingdom and to take over the kingdom for
himself he often employs various minions
and allies to help him achieve his goals
number four Ghidorah what do you know a
live action series centering on the king
of the Masters the series called
Godzilla and the Titans will reintroduce
the most of us died in apex predator
Gojira immediately following his battle
against the murals in 2014. aside from
the Grim horror stranger things series
Chris black and Matt fractions Godzilla
and the Titans is one of the most
anticipated American monster television
programs of this year the series is
intended to be a part of the most of us
and the producers have said that it
would feature ancient Titans as well as
adding new ones into The Fray so this
show might again feature Ghidorah either
in short scenes or in ancient bells or
being discovered by Monarch in
Antarctica before the events of King of
the Masters foreshadowing the
apocalyptic battle
number five the Targaryen dragons Okay
so be it vegar or caraxis or Cyrax or
vermethal one can only choose their
favorite dragon from the series this is
also a prequel to Game of Thrones House
of the Dragon season 2 will be featured
in 2024 and as the name suggests there
will be a lot of dragons to be seen
although in the first season the dragons
were only seen growing in size of flying
around fighting humans well except for
the last scene in the end of the last
episode the second season will showcase
Dragon on Dragon fights and this will be
one of the main themes aside from the
politics and squabbling among the
targaryens we can only wish for this to
be released sooner this year rather than
next year and that they don't got season
8 this show as well
number six damsel's dragon
Millie Bobby Brown is a monster chick
literally we can all agree on that
whether it is fighting against
interdimensional entities like the Mind
flayer or fighting alongside Godzilla
against Ghidorah or Mechagodzilla she
has done her name on the master Niche
what next fantasy so in this new fantasy
picture called damsel to be seen later
this year she would be a young woman who
believes that she is about to marry a
perfect Prince but is tossed into a pit
where she realizes that she will be
sacrificed to please a Savage dragon she
has to survive long enough for someone
to come and help her or save her but the
plot is that she would quickly realize
that no one is coming and that this
damsel must save herself and be the
heroine kinda lame and awoke storyline
but I'm more interested in the dragon
and what it would look like and how big
it would be or if it will bite one of
those ass cheeks
number seven Monster Hunter dragons so
there is a movie on the works a sequel
to last year's Monster Hunter which
featured wrathalos and Diablos two
weapons that are basically dragon types
Miller Djokovic starts as Natalie
Artemis a U.S Army Ranger who leads a
United Nations expedition in the desert
in Monster Hunter the first movie so
when her team is scored in a bizarre
storm they unintentionally cross into a
parallel realm populated by enormous
monsters and when it's all said and done
the threats of the other world seeps
into the real one in two hours monsters
will be larger and better in Monster
Hunter 2 and the gore magala will be the
main Dragon enemy well that's what I
hope or most of us do Monster Hunter 2
are not ancient elder dragons are one of
the deadliest creatures in fantasy and
we will be really happy if we get to see
them in live action
number eight yamatano oroji the movie
brush of the God was crowdfunded through
motion Gallery in September 2020 and is
set to be released in Autumn of this
year the brush of the Gods plot will
mostly revolve around humans with Kaiju
serving as a sporting role the following
spectacular affects Kaiju movie while
not made by Touhou is nonetheless one to
see the movie will include a slew of
massive creatures including the
eight-headed dragon Orochi Yamato no
Orochi who also resembles Ghidorah and
also not to be confused with the Titan
of the most of us bearing the same name
one that was only mentioned and not seen
Orochi here would probably be a side
figure but at the same time will have an
important role his eight heads is what I
most anticipate to see
and number nine the burp dragons in live
action so actually this movie or show
will be in production soon and is slated
to be released in 2025 but we have
decided to include it on this list How
to Train Your Dragon is an animated
series of movies that was very popular
and alongside its animated series and
comics turned into a massive franchise
the sheer number of dragons and dragon
designs would dwarf even Game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon combined
together not much is known about this
upcoming movie but we do know it would
be in live action with CGI that will
blow your mind away Toothless the Night
Fury would no doubt be a central figure
in this movie but the storyline might be
a little bit different as it would be
Bland to watch the same movie twice
so those are the 9 upcoming movie
dragons for 2023 onwards
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe and most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right now on this channel till
the next one take care fam